what do you get when you combine Pirates
of the Caribbean avatar and Star Wars
Episode two John Carter the novel was a
big inspiration to a lot of modern-day
science fiction films films like Star
Wars and now we have a big-budget Walt
Disney take on the novel it's about this
guy named John Carter and he kind of
gets zapped to Mars but it's in this
strange parallel universe like he was on
earth in the 1800s but it's not called
Mars it's called Barsoom and it's filled
with this race of people that are at war
there are these aliens that are at war
with this other group of aliens but
those aliens look like humans and the
other guys are green and they're
fighting basically John Carter arrives
and he realizes that because of his
human anatomy because the gravity is
used to on earth he can jump like super
far he's got he's really strong so
everyone starts to look at him as a
possible leader or someone who can put
an end to this war and John Carter meets
this princess who was very provocative
clothing at all times she of course is
about to be forced to be married to the
leader of the enemy and she of course
doesn't want to do that so John Carter
has to hopefully try to fix this war
problem and stop her from being married
to a guy she doesn't want to be married
to I was on the fence about John Carter
I wasn't entirely impressed by the
trailers but it was by Andrew Stannis
directed a lot of really good Pixar
movies and last year we had Brad Bird to
Pixar director they do with Mission
Impossible 4 which was great so I was
interested in seeing what a Pixar
director could do with live-action again
because it worked out last time and I
actually really liked this movie for the
first half of it it set up this world
really well it was actually really funny
and entertaining and a little bit
hilarious to see him trying to like
interact in the environment of Mars he's
tripping he's like walking around all
these people keep calling him weird
names because they can't understand his
language the first half really felt kind
of like a cross between parts of the
Caribbean and Avatar then the second
half happened and it really started to
look a lot like episode 2 Attack of the
Clones which as you may know is my least
favorite of all of them when he meets
the princess this incredibly stilted and
just completely stale wooden romance
starts where there's literally like no
chemistry I do not buy for a second that
they are interested in each other it
reminded me so much of the central
romance of episode 2 it's just so set up
there's even like this huge gladiator
sequence where like these bug like
creatures are watching like this guy has
to fight this giant beast just like at
the end of episode 2 it just went
completely off track the plot went every
we're totally convoluted the romance was
corny cheesy and unbelievable Taylor
Kitsch I don't know he did fine in the
film I think he was okay there was
nothing really that likeable about him
and I don't know if that's really his
fault or if it's just kind of how the
story went and when there's action on
the screen in this movie the spectacle
is there for sure I mean you're
impressed by the sheer scope of some of
these action scenes and the special
effects are really handled well there's
this great doglike alien in the movie
that runs incredibly fast so I really
wanted to like John Carter I enjoyed the
action scenes for what they were they
were well-done but towards the last half
it just got so fake and wooden and it
just lost all the charm of the first
half so since I enjoyed about half the
fell I'm going to give the film a C+ so
you guys have a favorite film that
involves Mars or space exploration in
general I really love space and
astronomy I think space is just awesome
and very intriguing so I'm interested in
seeing what you guys say if you liked
this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck my eyes
Oh